well it's great to see you here tonight
for the premiere they came together what
did you enjoy most about making this
movie oh boy I mean there were so many
things that were just great you know we
tried to make this movie over ten years
ago right after wet hot American summer
you know David Wain and Showalter that
written it and no one would ever give us
a dime to make it it's so silly and like
to work on stuff that's this silly is a
blast to do with people that you love
and are just really good friends with
you know Amy and I have known each other
for so many years and love working with
one another David and I have worked
together every one of David's movies I
mean the rest of the cast a lot of them
were in wet hot American summer it was
just great great I wanted to ask you
about working with David again of course
we loved what you've done together and
role models as well as fantastic I mean
the audience is looking forward to they
came together how does this compare to
previous movies you've worked on well I
think that in yeah in regard to the ones
I've done with David you know role
models was I think kind of something
that would try to make that was had
enough of his sensibility that it was
weird enough that it would appease David
Wain fans but then also kind of
straightforward and commercial enough
that it wouldn't a lien eight people I
think this maybe goes back a little bit
more to kind of wet hot American summer
in in tone even though it's different
and I do think it's accessible it's just
complete lunacy it's just dumb in in the
best way I think makes me laugh how much
do you enjoy that kind of comedy being
part of it I love working with David and
I love that I love the script and show
off there's an amazing writer with the
cast and the
and everything else I I love working on
it but the thing that I think David is
so good at it's just that it's so
specific - it's such a specific kind of
comedy and it's conveyor into invert
into an anti comedy thing same with
Showalter where the jokes sometimes are
just not there intentionally not even
intentionally bad they're intentionally
banal like they're nothing and it's a
that it's a he's not afraid to shy away
from that knowing that that kind of
thing might not appeal to everybody but
it completely slays me and and I love
doing that I love working with how much
kind of input do you get or improv and
that kind of thing when you're working
together on us quite a bit I mean we
were we collaborate we collaborate
Quebec although this you know this
script there's such great writers that I
mean the script is just absolutely
you've got coming up there's also been a
very long time in gestation its ant-man
and it's fantastic news to see that
you're in the lead role I mean how does
it feel to you to be part of that Marvel
verse well it's all just kind of
starting so it's it's really cool I'm
very excited about it Edgar Wright is
one boring British directors and Joe
Cornish as well from the great home from
Britain as well
- really talented guys what are you most
looking forward to about getting your
teeth into that Frodo and how much did
you kind of know about the Marvel World
and ant-man before you took it on do
some I mean I'd read I read some
comics and things and seeing movies and
but I and I knew Edgar has been friends
with Edgar for many years but the yeah
the whole like don't know whole thing
that it's actually happens that I got
the part it's still it's kind of surreal
it's still kind of sinking in over these
last several months how it's gonna come
and do you can we expect you to bring to
the role of a man no and we'll see what
I would ed ger has in mind and you know
we haven't started shooting anyways if
you got Michael Douglas has been
announced as well how excited you to be
working with him thrill I mean he's he's
amazing and Clark Gregg has actually
said that he would love to see you join
in the world of the agents of shield
would you be up for that
yeah he's great too I can't believe I
got an invitation to the party one final
question how much are you psyched to be
working again with rashida Jones I
follow what comes out online and even
then I don't quite follow those powers
that be announced what they want to
announce when they announce it but a lot
of this stuff you hear is not true to
see what you do the role and we look
forward to they came together as well
thanks so much few times
you